ça se mérite de recherche
toujours merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
et nous avoir rejoints vous êtes le chef
du service des urgences de l'hôpital
pompidou à paris faisait faire de la
garenne colombes et vous êtes candidat
également la primaire de la droite on va
évidemment en parler on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale bonjour julien lécuyer bonjour
rien on est ravi de vous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle saison julien lécuyer de
la voix du nord vient en plus julien on
commence évidemment en parlant de la
crise sanitaire film the mind
l'obligation vaccinale qui est donc
entré en vigueur hier pour les soignants
questions très concrètes d'abord comment
ça s'est traduit dans votre hôpital quel
est le taux de soignants non vaccinés
est ce que cette obligation a eu des
conséquences concrètes sur le
fonctionnement des durs j'en écoutais
sur les urgences on doit être à peu près
150 181 tous les médecins sont vaccinés
quelques-uns n'ont pas encore entrées
lors leur badge dans la machine mais ça
va être régularisé il y à toutes les
infirmières également deux ou trois
aides soignants n'ont pas souhaité être
vaccinées donc son ne viendront pas
travailler aujourd'hui vous comprenez
c'est cette stratégie la stratégie du
gouvernement qui consistent d'interdire
de venir travailler mais pourra
soignants c'est logique d'être vacciné
parce que c'est ainsi aussi que vous
protégez ce dont vous devez prendre soin
donc c'est logique la difficulté qu'elle
et elle sait que partout en france nous
manquons d'infirmières et
d'aides-soignantes partout il n'y a pas
un hôpital où il n'y ait pas des lits
fermés aujourd'hui à cause du manque de
personnel donc la vraie le vrai sujet
c'est que ce type de mesure va aggraver
la situation
aujourd'hui à presque vous met en
difficulté ça va nous mettre un peu plus
en difficulté que le sable nous le
sommes déjà il ya
probablement enfin ça dépend des
hôpitaux mais moi je connais des
hôpitaux il ya 20 25% de lits fermés
aujourd'hui à cause du manque
d'infirmières ou d'aides-soignants ça ne
peut qu'aggraver les choses monsieur je
viens vous avez été par le passé très
critique vis-à-vis de la stratégie
sanitaire du gouvernement là on va
bientôt atteindre les 50 millions de
primo vacciner ce qui est la couverture
vaccinale la plus importante au monde
est ce que finalement ça justifie pas la
prise de position radicale du président
le 12 juillet dernier a d'abord il faut
arrêter de dire qu'on est les champions
du monde à ce jeu c'est qu'on est
toujours les meilleurs en foot en
éducation en santé non en attendant
souvent elles se dégradent à se délivrer
un vrai il ya des pays qui font mieux
que nous d'abord premièrement je pense
que le président la république a eu
raison au mois de juillet et à l'époque
moi j'ai dit que ce qu'il avait dit été
très bien c'est probablement grâce à son
intervention du mois de juillet qu'on a
vu une accélération des choses donc
c'était très bien aujourd'hui les choses
vont bien mieux sauf deux catégories
d'âge qu'il faut avoir en tête nous ne
sommes pas bons sur les très âgés on va
dire que 85 ou plus de 75 ans surtout
plus de 85 où nous avons eu un taux de
couverture qui n'est pas suffisant qui
est très inférieur à celui de nos
voisins
nos pays d'une les pays du nord d'europe
du nord c'est dû à quoi selon vous c'est
le mien à quasiment 100% nous on est
plutôt à 85 90 % c'est lié au fait que
nous avons une stratégie qui est très
homogène et qui n'est pas différencié
selon les patients il ya des gens par
exemple qui sont chez eux qu'ils ne
peuvent pas bouger de chez eux de gens
âgés les gens âgés qui est utilisé en
difficulté info à marcher à sortir et on
ne va pas suffisamment les chercher chez
eux donc il ya un premier effort à faire
sur les très âgés et un deuxième a fait
un effort à faire sur la tranche de 12
17 ans qui est insuffisamment vaccinés
par ses ors c'est une tranche qui
probablement va participer d'une manière
importante à l'entretien de
l'épidémie moi je souhaite qu'on aille
vacciner très facilement dans les
collèges et les lycées faudrait qu'il y
ait des centres de vaccination mobile ce
sera jean michel ankaragücü dossard
proposé aux collégiens aux lycéens et
c'est à la fin du mur c'est jean michel
drucker et nous a promis plein de trucs
depuis un an et demi en particulier des
autotests partout etc moi je n'ai jamais
rien vu les écoliers et les lycéens et
les collégiens français sont testés 100
fois moins qu'en grande bretagne donc
les projets qu'on nous propose sont
toujours de beaux projets la question
c'est la mise en oeuvre allez manquer
traitement il a manqué la rentrée
scolaire ce
qu'il a dit la semaine dernière qui
avait 3000 enfants aux 3000 écoles trois
classes étaient fermés moi je dis
simplement une chose en grande bretagne
quand vous êtes
c'est un collégien on vous donne deux
fois par semaine un autotest à faire
chez vous vous même vous êtes positif je
n'allais pas à l'école vous êtes négatif
vous re oui et vous avez négatif vous
allez à l'école en france on n'a pas
cette politique d'autotest et donc on
attend qu apparaisse un cas dans une
école évidemment quand le cac est apparu
dans la classe c'est qu'il y en a en
fait beaucoup plus et je crains qu'on
ait des classes qui ferment d'une
manière importante dans les semaines qui
viennent oui je pense que la stratégie
scolaire n'est pas la bonne un dernier
mot sur cette vaccination obligatoire
les sénateurs socialistes vont déposer
un texte au sénat va examiner un texte
le 13 octobre prochain à l'initiative
des sénateurs socialistes pour
l'obligation vaccinale pour tous est ce
que vous vous êtes fait avoir pour tout
souvenir toute la population de la
population et je leur ai fait toujours
la même réponse imaginez je suis votre
médecin vous êtes ma patiente et vous
dites je ne veux pas être vacciné je
vous dise est obligatoire vous dites je
ne veux pas qu est ce que je fais je
vous attache sur votre siège et puis je
vous injecte contre votre gré non
ça c'est le principe même si on sait
tout mais pas donc ans est obligatoire
comment faites vous pour les mineures
mais il ya même même dans ce cas là il
n'y a jamais été il ya jamais eu l'idée
d'aller contre et de contraindre
quelqu'un à se vacciner alors s'ils sont
factuels sivm de longuenée comme s'ils
vous contraignez contraignait pas
comment rendez-vous les choses
obligatoires moi ce qui m'intéresse
c'est pas le discours c'est comment on
fait en pratique quand vous dites c'est
obligatoire dites moi comment vous
faites pour rendre les choses
obligatoire pour des enfants on le sait
en fait pour des enfants c'est connu
depuis des décennies la vaccination
obligatoire est telle que si vous votre
enfant n'est pas vacciné vous n'entrez
pas à l'école par exemple est ce que là
si nous ne sommes pas vacciner est-ce
qu'il est prévu par cette loi que demain
vous ne pourrez plus aller travailler
vous ne pourrez plus prendre le métro
c'est ça la sanction la vraie ce le vrai
sujet c'est la mise en oeuvre donc je ne
crois surtout si vous n'êtes pas content
oui je ne suis pas contre mais je ne
crois pas à la mise en oeuvre je pense
qu'elle est impossible et je pense qu'il
faut faire ce qu'on n'a pas fait
suffisamment depuis six mois tout cas
moi c'est ce que je ferai des campagnes
d'information ciblées parce
qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a jamais eu de
campagne d'information expliquant aux
gens qui sont rebelles pour des raisons
de craintes par exemple au vaccin
pourquoi le vaccin est bon il ya le clip
sympa avec la grand-mère qui aura ses
petits-enfants mais ce n'est pas ça qui
va persuader les gens méfiants peut-être
une dernière question je ne sais pas sur
sûre en tout cas la crise sanitaire
comment vous jugez la mise en examen de
l'ex-ministre de la santé agnès buzyn
pour mise en danger de la vie d'autrui
je crois que c'est totalement
déraisonnable nous assistons à une
judiciarisation permanente de la vie
politique où tous les hommes et les
femmes politiques ont une sorte d'épée
de damoclès qui est là qui les menace
pour tous dans ces cas là il faut mettre
en examen monsieur le maire parce que le
déficit n'a jamais été aussi grand
depuis 1949 il faut mettre en examen
le patron de l'équipe de france de
football parce que nous sommes pas
arrivés à avoir de bons résultats où
va-t-on aller où vas tu waris est une
dérive de la cour de justice de la
république moi je crois que c'est une
dérive générale de la société qui tend à
régler ses problèmes à travers la
justice quand vous voulez sanctionner un
homme ou une femme politique est un
moyen très simple ça s'appelle
l'élection d'ailleurs madame blizzard a
perdu l'élection à paris et bien c'est
une sanction suffisante on va passer un
mot tu viens on va parler sécurité
maintenant je t'aime qui est en effet
très en vogue en ce moment puisqu'il ya
eu à la fois les le discours le grand
discours d' emmanuel macron à l'école de
police de roubaix et le lendemain la
réponse de xavier bertrand à
saint-quentin alors partons d'abord
d'emmanuel mâcon qui a détaillé mardi
ses propositions il y avait dix mille
renfort à 10000 renforts attendus 1,4
milliard en plus de budget est ce que ça
va dans le bon sens seul bout mais on
n'est jamais dans la communication en
fait ça saute aux yeux vos confrères de
brut la fameuse chaîne brut si célèbre
chez le président de la république a mis
en scène depuis hier une vidéo où il
compara discours d' emmanuel macron en
2017 et le discours de il ya quelques
jours des manuels macron ce sont
quasiment les mêmes mots et ce soit les
mêmes propositions il nous promet
aujourd'hui ce qu'il promettait en 2017
et qui n'a pas fait donc qui est un
problème de violence et de délinquance
c'est évident la france 7 ans sauvage et
il ya des quartiers où la loi
républicaine ne règle pas les peines ne
sont pas appliquées voilà quand vous
êtes condamné en fait vous ne faites pas
vos peines prenez l'exemple des travaux
d'intérêts généraux quand vous êtes trop
d'années un travail d'intérêt général
que dans 20% des cas vous ne faites pas
du tout dans 80% des cas vous le faites
je crois 425 jours après la commission
des faits autant dire que l'exemplarité
ne fonctionne pas il a vraiment rien
fait les effectifs ont été augmenté les
budgets ont été votés il ya des choses
qui ont été faites de 8000 8000 forces
de l'ordre en plus depuis le début du
quinquennat je rappelle que quand la
droite y étaient au pouvoir il ya eu des
baisses donc rien à la question pardon
n'est pas de savoir si on veut s'il ya
plus ou pas au policier
à quoi sert un peu non mais non si je
veux dire à quoi sert un policier qui
fait des procurations dans un
commissariat à quoi sert un policier qui
surveille une sous-préfecture où il ne
se passe jamais rien la vraie question
je crois enfin c'est ma proposition donc
candidat c'est de dire il faut redéfinir
les missions de la police m les
policiers sur le terrain moins de
charges administratives s'excuse de
moyens et ce que dit le président de
deezer doublement doublement des
effectifs sur le terrain d'ici lisait en
2010 est déjà où il continue à le dire
au moins il est constant dans ses
promesses la question est de savoir
combien de quinquennat il faut pour
arriver à mettre en place une promesse
moi je ça peut-être un deuxième cela dit
mais voyez vous on est dans cette
politique qui ne qui n'est qu'une vaste
agence de communication la france est
une agence de com ou au fait des
annonces peu importe que sur le terrain
on les voit ou non la conséquence je
vous dis moi je suis maire c'est que je
vois que sur le terrain il ya moins de
moyens je vois que sur le terrain il ya
plus de délinquance tous mes collègues
maires s'en plaignent on voit qu à une
délinquance de proximité qui existe est
- il ya quelques années c'est ans
sauvagement il faut la résoudre c'est à
la fois la police et la fois de la
justice justement sur ce beau mot
puisque vous êtes maire on a entendu les
élus locaux
ce n'était pas forcément à ses associés
à ce que vous aussi je n'ai cessé votre
pas été assez social de la sécurité
je crois moi qu'il faut rendre
obligatoires les polices municipales
pour les villes de plus de 10 mille
habitants je crois deuxièmement qu'il
faut rendre obligatoire l'armement des
polices municipales seules 60% des
polices municipales sont armés
aujourd'hui et je crois enfin que les
policiers municipaux doivent avoir les
mêmes prérogatives que les policiers
nationaux ça ce n'est malheureusement
pas proposé alors est-ce que vous
rejoignez aussi quelques-unes des
propositions faites par xavier bertrand
à saint-quentin alors il a parlé par
exemple d'une extension de la période de
sûreté à 50 ans voire même de la
rétroactivité de cette de cette mesure
quitte à passer par un référendum
puisque à l'heure actuelle ce serait
anticonstitutionnel est ce que vous le
rejoignez là dessus dont j'avoue que je
ne rejoins pas xavier bertrand chaussée
sur ces sujets là je le rejoins sur une
philosophie générale qui est de rendre
les peines prononcées exécutable
premièrement je mange je pense qu'il
manque dans notre arsenal juridique une
loi spécifique sur la délinquance en
bandes quand vous avez une bande qui
cassent ou qu'ils fallaient qui cause
des violences à personnes on ne sait
jamais qui a porté le coup qui avait la
batte de baseball etc c'est pas moi
c'est l'autre et finalement tout le
monde s'en sort moi je suis pour une loi
qui consisterait à dire toute personnes
qui participent à une action violente
dans une bande violente et responsable
comme on dit d'une manière et dans in
solidum c'est à dire en solidarité et
tous sont pareillement responsable avec
ça on met fin au à la délinquance en
bandes qui est un fléau dans nos villes
autre sujet l'éducation alors autre
sujet puisque en plus nous on la rentrée
scolaire vous avez fait une proposition
choc qui qui va forcément surprendre un
peu les professeurs allongée de quatre
semaines l'année scolaire alors vous
dites que ça permettrait de rattraper la
moyenne des pays de l'osce et des hommes
et vous proposez quoi en échange la
situation est assez simple en france il
ya 162 jours par an d'école dans les
pays de l' ocde il ya 22 jours de plus
22 ou 23 ça dépend comment on compte
c'est à dire presque un mois la
conséquence c'est quoi c'est que non
seulement il ya moins de temps pour
apprendre et c'est une des raisons qui
fait que nous décrocherons dans tous les
classements internationaux
tous les classements internationaux de
l'école français et dernière maintenant
et les l'année scolaire est plus dense
les enfants sont crevés donc moi je
propose qu'on se mettre au niveau des
pays de l' ocde quatre semaines de cours
en plus c'est à dire deux semaines ou
mois de juillet de vacances en moins une
semaine en moins la toussaint une
semaine au moins on février avec ça on
remonte au niveau de nos voisins et
j'espère que ça contribuera à
l'augmentation du niveau comprenez que
le sujet est fondamental l'école
française est en train de tomber nous
sommes dernier par exemple au classement
de mathématiques alors qu'est ce qu'on
fait on continue à regarder en disant à
ses formes et câble on a un bon système
snow notre système est catastrophique
nous n'avons pas les résultats que nous
devrions avoir la conséquence c'est que
20 ans plus tard et bien vous n'avez pas
de vaccins qui sont fabriqués en france
à votre avis vous saviez tout ça et donc
ma question visait aussi à savoir ce que
vous proposiez en échange aux
professeurs professeur est ce que ça se
vaut si ça peut se manifester une poire
une une hausse de salaire conséquente
alors je vous propose peut-être pas le
doublement des salaires tel que le
propose anne hidalgo mais vous pensez
pas qu'il ya là aussi un effort à faire
écoutez je veux dire qu'aujourd'hui la
france est dans une situation où il ya
sans cesse % d'endettement moi je veux
bien qu'on distribue les zorro comme sa
part de l'argent magique comme on vous
l'a jugé cette proposition
écoutez tout ça est très intéressant il
faut simplement qu'elle nous dise d'où
ça vient est ce que c'est de
l'endettement supplémentaire ou de
l'impôt supplémentaire moi je crois si
vous voulez que l'école à une priorité
c'est de donner un enseignement aux
enfants
et donc ma priorité c'est de monter le
niveau je monte le niveau en faisant ça
je monte le niveau en faisant une
deuxième chose enfin de cm1 vous savez
qu on a 10% 10 à 15% des enfants qui ne
savent pas lire et écrire correctement
ni compter en sixième autant vous dire
que quand ils entrent en sixième avec ce
ce sac très lourd d'insuffisances il ne
rattrape jamais au niveau et c'est comme
ça vous avez des décrocheurs je propose
que fan c'est m on évalue la totalité
des enfants de france tous ceux qui
n'ont pas le niveau en fin de ses mains
pour passer en sixième un an plus tard
eh bien on les met dans des cm2 ils
passent en cm2 mais on l'aimé danse des
cm2 avec huit à dix élèves seulement et
grâce à ces renforcements des capacités
pédagogiques en cm2 et bien un certain
nombre de ces élèves voulaient remonter
au niveau et vous les fait passer en
sicile comprenez que quand vous passez
en sixième avec les savoirs fondamentaux
vous êtes sauvés aujourd'hui ce n'est
pas le cas et pour reprendre la question
de julien sur les profs aucune
augmentation de salaire pour vous moi je
ne sais pas où est l'argent je joue je
ne sais pas répondre à cette question je
pense qu'effectivement il faudra pour la
discute on verra où redistribue les
postes moi je crois qu'il faut renforcer
la fonction publique en général la
fonction publique en général par
redistribution de postes nous
semble-t-il il ya trois cent mille
enseignants qui aujourd'hui ne sont pas
face à des élèves et bien c'est
peut-être une marge de manoeuvre une
masse de marge de manoeuvre que l'on
pourrait utiliser pour renforcer les
classes de cm2 monsieur je vais alors
autres autre sujet d'actualité votre
famille politique continue d'abreuver la
chronique quotidienne des tractations
autour de la méthode de départage qui
doit vous permettre à tous les candidats
de la droite et du centre de d'arrivée
seul pour représenter votre famille au
moment de la présidentielle on avait
compris la semaine dernière qu'il y
avait trois pistes de travail cette
semaine ça se réduit à 2 franchement
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer où
on en est là à l'heure actuelle c'est
très simple en fait comprenez que si au
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle il ya deux candidats de
la droite et du centre on a perdu
l'élection présidentielle donc il m'en
faut qu'un comment fait on est-ce qu'on
attend comme ça qu'il ya un signe du
ciel en disant c'est lui ou c'est elle
ça ne marche pas nous n'avons pas de
candidat naturel pour le désigner le
candidat comment fait-on ont fait par le
vote donc nous allons demander à nos
militants 25 septembre de choisir entre
deux méthodes
soit le candidat sera désigné par tous
les adhérents du parti les adhérents du
parti seulement soit le candidat sera
désigné par les adhérents du parti et
tous ceux qui non adhérents du parti se
désigneront comme sympathisants de la
droite et du centre il ya deux méthodes
sur la table le 25e sur laquelle a votre
préférence le plus la plus ouverte
possible je pense que dans une société
très ouverte où tout le monde a son avis
sur tous les gars vous savez que
maintenant on à 67 millions de
microbiologistes en france donc il
serait normal que tout le monde ait la
parole je pense que la droite et ça doit
être une droite et du centre la plus
ouverte possible
qui n'appartiennent plus à l'air est ce
que l'autre méthode et d'envisageable de
réserver il faut l'écarter suffisamment
précieux en faites ce que je vous ai
décrit la scène corps électoral mais
toute personne qui veut participer à
cette primaire qu'elle soit organisée
avec un
accord électoral qui ne serait que les
adhérents ou les adhérents plus et
sympathisants toute personne peut y
participer xavier comme bertrand comme
valérie pécresse a jugé cela dit en
effet xavier bertrand lui a déjà dit non
à une primaire ouverte à on sent que le
vote des militants seul pourrait
peut-être l'intéressé mais j'allais dire
presque dès lors que son avancée et et
conforter le sondage commandé la part la
direction des républicains à l'ifop pour
déterminer qui représenterait au mieux
les intérêts de la de votre famille
politique à la présidentielle doit
sortir bientôt alors vous pouvez
peut-être nous dira d'ailleurs quand
est-ce qu'il doit sortir exactement où
quelques jours avant 2,25 donc j'imagine
aux alentours du genre d'accord est ce
que pour vous il peut être un peu ce
juge de paix il pourrait l'être si
effectivement vous aviez un candidat
très largement devant comme peut-être
nicolas sarkozy il était une époque où
la droite est ce que ça sera le cas on
va le voir probablement aucun candidat
ne se démarquera bref il confirmera ce
que je vous disais il ya deux minutes
c'est l'absence de candidat naturel dès
lors vous n'avez pas de candidat naturel
vous devez avoir un moyen pour désigner
notre candidat c'est serré jusqu'au bout
du choix vous prêt vous rallier en
compte da avant la mise en place du mode
de désignation c'est à dire est ce que
je devais être candidat jusqu'au bout
mais pourquoi ne serais-je pas non mais
vous avez vu l'état de la dune à france
et le nombre de gens qui vont voter aux
élections une des raisons de sa c'est ce
sont ces parcours politique des hommes
et des femmes qui sont tous les mêmes
moi j'ai un parcours différent et je
pense qu'avec ce parcours différent qui
est riche mais qui est différent j'ai
fait des choses que d'autres n'ont pas
fait beaucoup de choses que d'autres
n'ont pas fait eh bien ça peut
intéresser je me permet de relancer la
question dorian c'est en fait ce qu'on
essaye de comprendre c'est de savoir si
en effet un candidat se détachait qui
n'est pas vous hélas durant l'automne
avance suffisamment confortable pour
dire voilà qu'il s'impose naturellement
est ce que vous pouvez imaginer de vous
dire bien je me place derrière lui
puisqu'il semble mieux armé parler bien
sûr mais là il n'ya pas de doute si un
candidat a été largement devant
spontanément d'une manière constante et
à pâques et sondages plus on sent les
choses aillent évidemment oui monsieur
d'accord c'est quel que soit ce candidat
de la droite et du centre de valeur ça
serait bien une petite question aussi
sur eric zemmour qui me qu'on voit
monter dans les seins dans les sondages
8% lors d'un dernier sondage un risque
et ce qui est là un risque d'éclatement
de votre électorat non je ne crois pas
en fait eric zemmour d'abord il n'est
pas candidat il l'a dit lui-même et
si je suis candidat dans ces cas là
emmanuel macron est il candidat avoué
est ce que c'est pour ça qu'on compte on
décompte le temps de parole de
l'événement ce qui le sera pas je ne
sais pas je veux que je ne sais pas
d'une certaine manière à quoi ça sert de
passer son temps à prévoir un avenir qui
ne dépend pas de vous donc moi je ne
regarde pas le jour où il ira je suis
candidat et les candidats puis on
discutera je lisais moore quand il dit
qu'il ya des zones de non droit il a
raison en tout le monde dos à ce que je
vous disais il ya cinq minutes quand il
dit qu'il ya une immigration massive et
incontrôlée familiale en particulier il
a raison je le dis aussi et j'ai des
propositions je pense qu'il faut qu'on
arrête l'immigration familiale en
revanche quand il explique que quand
vous appelez rachid et karim vous n'êtes
pas réellement intégré à la communauté
nationale c'est aussi ce qu'il a
expliqué je pense qu'ils se trompent et
que c'est une erreur extrêmement
dommageable pour le pays et vous pouvez
vous appeler karim avoir un métier
vouloir le meilleur pour vos enfants
travailler payer vos impôts respecter
les lois et c'est évidemment l'extrême
majorer la quasi majorité de tous les
crimes et les rachid de france la france
a besoin de d'apaisement je n'aime pas
les propositions en fait c'est
probablement qu'au caractère qui
fragmentent le pays qui fragmentent les
français on peut avoir des idées
différentes sur les choses mais nous
sommes français la nation c'est ça la
nation c'est que nos points communs sont
plus importants que ceux qui nous
diffère les en parlant de deux points
communs et imaginer qu'il y ait un
second tour entre eric zemmour et
emmanuel macron pour qui voterez-vous
non mais vous savez on nous a fait le
coup imaginer maquereau et le pen
maintenant imaginez macro et zemmour ça
va durer jusqu'à quand et il a tranché
nuit est ce que vous trancher comme non
mais non mais d'avoir moi je et reese et
vous on n'est pas ma tasse de thé je
voulais dit il fractionne le pays en
disant à des gens qui travaillent qui
veulent un avenir pour leurs enfants
qu'ils respectent les lois de la
république vous ne serez jamais français
que moi c'est un problème majeur
fractionné est-ce qu'il est dangereux
mais non enfin chez eux dangereux je ne
sais pas est ce que eric zemmour est
armé et tirant les
gendarmes larmes elle des idées
il ne faut pas le caricaturer les
postures des uns et les autres en
politique moi je n'ai aucun ennemi j'ai
des adversaires que je combats sur le
terrain des idées et je le combattrai
sur le terrain des idées cette idée en
particulier je crois qu'ils qui n'est
pas une idée indie bonne donc je me
refuse à faire des pronostics sur des
zoulous tour dans ces cas là c'est sans
fin c'est à nous les républicains de
montrer que le second tour entre
emmanuel macron et marine le pen ou
d'autres n'est pas inéluctable je
croyais merci beaucoup merci d'avoir été
avec nous ce matin je n'ai regardé la
une de la voix du nord l'emploi repart
c'est à la une de votre journal ce matin
vraies bonnes gens de très bonnes
nouvelles
merci beaucoup
[Musique]